erfahren holt als politiker haben sie
ich habe gerade schon gesagt voll auf
erneuerbare energien gesetzt das erste
windrad in der nordsee das ist nach ihm
benannt das heißt fritz dass sie uns
auch immer noch das heißt immer noch fit
und haben sie trotzdem inzwischen den
glauben verloren an die energiepolitik
hier in deutsch ich habe ja immer die
erneuerbaren energien unterstützt
allerdings war mir immer klar wir werden
die in der lage seien 100 prozent zu
machen weil wir haben natürliche
schwankungen wir haben eben mal auch
zehn tage kein wind wie jetzt zum
beispiel und wir haben eben auch im
winter und nachts fallen die keine sonne
also erneuerbare energien funktionieren
dann wenn sie einen backup haben und das
ist glaube ich das geheimnis
der aktuellen krise nicht wir haben uns
auf dem backup von gas verlassen wir
haben die kernenergie abgestellt haben
die kohle abgestellt und jetzt wundern
wir uns dass
erneuerbare energien zusammen heute also
wind und sonne
5,1 prozent des primärenergieverbrauchs
abdecken strom haben sie in größeren
anteilen zusammen aber wir reden ja über
wärme mobilität wir wundern uns sagen
sie das heißt wir alle vor allen dingen
etwas völlig falsch eingeschätzt völlige
fehlkalkulation
die regierung hat in ihrer letzten
koalitionsvereinbarung ja angekündigt
sie wollten noch 30 neue gaskraftwerke
bauen weil ihr bekannt war und bewusst
war jetzt wollte man mehr erneuerbare
machen noch mehr windräder noch mehr
sonne die dann nachts nicht scheint also
muss man noch mehr gaskraftwerke bauen
das war der hintergrund für nord stream
2 man braucht er wird putins gas wollte
man die energiewende absichern und das
ist gescheitert der kurse dass er sie
grad da reden wir jetzt im zeitraffer
dass die energiewende werde so
gescheitert jetzt in den nächsten
monaten uns wirklich zum absturz bringen
kann sie haben sich verkalkuliert sagte
fahren heute sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag sich immer auf das
gesetzt was jetzt halt nicht
funktioniert was sie jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr wollen wir wären die
gaskraftwerke trotzdem brauchen nicht
erklären auch warum weil genau das
stimmt was verfahren halten hat er
vollkommen recht wenn er sagt wir haben
die sonne und wind nicht immer zur
verfügung das bedeutet wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir aus sonne und wind so
viel energie produzieren und umwandeln
dass sie auch zur verfügung steht wenn
sonne und wind mal nicht zur verfügung
stehen und das bedeutet wir brauchen für
den ausbau der erneuerbaren nicht nur
mehr es gibt ja in zukunft nicht nur ein
kraftwerk auf der nordsee sondern wir
planen 70 gigawatt im moment sind es elf
sondern wir müssen auch dafür sorgen
dass das was überschüssig ist und das
wird immer mehr dass wir das mitnehmen
wenn die zeiten wo wir keine
erneuerbaren haben zum beispiel über die
umwandlung in wasserstoff und das
schaffen wir nur wenn wir im
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz was wir
jetzt gerade verhandeln eine speicher
strategie implementieren und dann
endlich den einstieg finden dass wir die
erneuerbaren auch haben wenn sie nicht
zu vergessen klingt jetzt alles so
optimistisch aber tatsächlich ist
totaler pessimismus gerade angesagt in
der regierung nach dem was er habe
gesagt hat ende dieser woche der stellt
uns im grunde darauf ein dass aus der
dass die heizung nicht mehr anspringt
sagt dass wir weniger duschen müssen wie
dicht stehen wir herr boris an einem
blackout im herbst im winter ich glaube
wir haben alle nicht auf dem schirm
gehabt kein politiker kein gutachter
dass eine situation seit dem 24 2
eintritt die man im grunde mit einem
wirtschaftsembargo kriegs
wirtschaftsembargo bezeichnen kann von
seiten russlands die wirtschaftswoche
hat vor kurzem gesagt kriegs
mangelwirtschaft die ausgerufen wird
wenn wir eine abhängigkeit von den
teilweise 52 55 prozent gas haben
importe aus russland 30 prozent schafft
norwegen 18 12 prozent schafften die
niederlande dann muss uns bewusst sein
dass eine einseitige abhängigkeit von
einem großen lieferanten sehr sehr
gefährlich wird wenn derjenige uns jetzt
den gashahn stückchenweise zu dritt wir
haben das haus sierung auf 60 dann
müssen wir uns sehr kurzfristig gedanken
machen was wird in den nächsten wochen
monaten das ist plan eines krisen
management und uns bereitet die sorge
dass wir in einen kalten herbst in einen
sehr kalten winter reihen laufen und wir
dürfen nicht auf das prinzip hoffnung
setzen sondern wir brauchen jetzt
ersatzlösung kurzfrist also dieser
blackout das ist kein horrorszenario
mehr sondern das ist ein szenario was
sie nicht ausschließen können da kann
man derzeit nicht ausschließen
insbesondere werden wichtige energie die
träger wegbrechen wir haben zum beispiel
12 bis 16 prozent für gaskraftwerke
wenn ich diese gasmengen nicht mehr habe
ist die frage wie viel kann ich noch in
die gaskraftwerke stecken also fällt ein
wichtiger part raus in wenigen wochen in
wenigen monaten gehen die letzten drei
akw vom netz wir wollen zahlreiche
kohlekraftwerke bis 2030 35 stilllegen
dann müssen wir fragen wie können wir
das subsumieren über 24 stunden am tag 7
tage die woche 365 tage im jahr auch
wenn die sonne nicht scheint und bin der
wind nicht weht freuen sie ist er jetzt
ein paar jahre genau jetzt schon an
einer show nacht und heute diese wenigen
jetzt ein gesetz das dafür sorgt dass
wir jetzt feste klimaaktivisten da habe
ich gesagt sie greifen zu radikalen
mitteln festkleben auf der straße
kanzleramt beschmieren hungerstreik
haben sie gemacht mitten im wahlkampf im
gespräch zu erzwingen mit den
spitzenkandidaten freunde sich jetzt
über diese energiekrise in deutschland
weil sie wollen ja sowieso 1 sie wollen
das land was die energie angeht
runterfahren ja ich frage mich wie sich
irgendwer freuen kann der aktuellen
situation die ja krisengeschüttelt ist
wie kaum eine zuvor ich glaube im
übrigen dass die leute die auf die
erhitzung aufmerksam machen und auch auf
die weiteren gefahren von fossilen
energien dass man kriegstreiber
unterstützt und terrorregime überall in
der welt nicht nur russland aber jetzt
gerade natürlich am deutlichsten dass
man hätte man auf die gehört darin leben
zu sagen man baut um jetzt gar nicht in
dieser scheiße so tief drin stecken
würde mal salopp gesagt ich bin hier bei
die richtigen fragen glaube ich weil ich
denke die richtige frage heißt jetzt
eigentlich warum reden wir noch nicht
über die verbundenheit von all diesen
krisen miteinander also der erhitzung
auch eben einer welt in der es immer
mehr darum geht wer hat zugang zu
nahrungsmitteln es wird ja ungemein
vielen der ukraine in russland
produziert an weizen und insgesamt
stellen wir die größten
hungerkatastrophe der
menschheitsgeschichte das ist
klimakatastrophe plus krieg und weswegen
ich hier bin ist glaube ich um zu sagen
wir schaffen es immer noch nicht die
richtigen lösungen zu finden wenn wir
das problem nicht in gänze betrachten
das heißt es entstehen todeszone um den
äquator und es werden allein in diesem
jahrzehnt 700 millionen menschen sich
aus dem afrikanischen kontinent
lebensbedrohlichen situationen befinden
wenn wir nicht aufhören diese ergänzung
weiter anzutreiben das ganze wird
soziale konflikte bringen die leute die
jetzt gerade neu geboren sind in
deutschland die werden erleben wie der
krieg weiter wie weitere kriege
entstehen wie vielleicht sehr rekrutiert
werden müssen wie das ganze richtig
ekelhaft wieder werden wird in der
gesellschaft an den grenzen ich glaube
ein rechtsstaat kann das nicht überleben
was dann an klimakatastrophe kommt
extrem wetter und so weiter hitze wald
wir erleben ist halt die frage und
dennis vorsorgen und wir sagen es hält
sich die regierung nicht an die
verfassung die die lebensgrundlagen
nicht schützt und damit eben uns
weiterhin kriege führt aber freuen sie
sich darüber dass jetzt das land
heruntergefahren wird das jetzt appelle
von der regierung kommen ihr müsst
sparen sparen sparen energie sparen das
ist doch genau ihr thema das wollen sie
doch also das find ich jetzt ein
bisschen absurd glauben sie dass wir
eine freude daran haben dass es den
menschen irgendwie schlecht ist dass ich
mich an straße auf eine straße setzte um
also glauben sie dass mir das freude
macht ja doch ich bin hier ich wollte es
sehr wenn es frau ich bin hier um zu
erzählen dass die richtige frage jetzt
eigentlich diese warum redet immer noch
niemand darüber was ich gerade gesagt
habe ich gerne dass die nächste als
nächstes geschehe zu sagen wann eine
klima erhitzung und den sorgen getragen
werden wird die schauen sich den
deutschen wald doch an nochmal ja was
erzählen sie denn den menschen also die
jetzt gerade evakuiert werden in den
waldbränden deutsche warten geht richtig
gut so gut wie noch lange nicht und sie
müssen einfach ein bisschen aufpassen
dass sie unter den jungen menschen nicht
solche angst psychosen verbreiten lesen
sie bitte den weltklimabericht und der
sagt ihm wenn wir so weitermachen und
die pariser ziele erfüllen was
allerdings nicht für china gilt nicht
will sie wissen die china ein
entwicklungsland darf immer weiter co2
emittieren darüber müssen wir
diskutieren aber wenn man das so machen
dann haben wir in 2060
22 grad ja und wir haben 2040 haben wir
0,3 grad mehr das ist auch keine
katastrophe
darauf kann man sich doch anpassen sie
müssen doch mal ein bisschen zu den
fakten kommt lehren sie doch bitte mal
einmal die 2000 seiten des klima
berichts und dann diskutieren wir
bekommen sie es gelesen ich glaube wir
haben alle gelesen was da ist setzen wir
auf die wirtschaft heraus gekommen sind
haben sie eben dass der veränderung sie
kann nicht 30 das können wir nach der
sendung terrorismus ich jetzt vielleicht
mal klarstellen die bekannten muss nicht
berichte von 3000 seiten länge neu delhi
bericht als auch die aktive latsch wäre
schon super sound sich mal an die
bevölkerung brauchen einfacher sprache
jetzt die warnung was das bedeutet was
da drinsteht was da drinsteht was das
bedeutet sie haben doch keine ahnung
erzählen sie doch mal wie die realität
ist das ziemlich egal was sie dir das
eigentlich weise jetzt machen wir einmal
schnitt bei 1 führt die muss ich schauen
die für die zuschauer machen einen super
draht jetzt schon hören inzwischen 1,4
die zuschauer ist es in dem fall wichtig
welche katastrophe man sich widmen soll
sie haben gesagt welche katastrophe für
sie wichtig ist